a week and a half ago Wardell got called
out by trick for queuing with a known
stream sniper but now trick is also
being called out for occasionally
smurfing when queuing up with some of
his friends but is smurfing as bad as
stream sniping and will either problem
ever really go
away all right before we get into the
video I just want to remind you that we
have merch head to shop. thecore
docomo collection where there's a P of
cool hoodies t-shirts and crew necks to
purchase so don't miss out so I'm sure
by now many of you have already seen
these
clips he's behind his wall and then boat
let's let's play 4B again let's play 4B
again let's hide
though how Shameless are you
shamess but if you haven't let me
explain to you what's been happening in
the world of valorant streaming there's
stream sniping drama the Raina on
wardell's team named kitty meow meow was
calling out enemy locations and gamble
Stacks which basically just means
stacking a site with your teammates and
you also might have noticed that they
were echoing on W El stream hm I wonder
why trick was on the enemy team probably
thinking to himself wow these guys have
the read on us every single round and he
was queued with G2 net at the time who
warned him that kitty meow meow is a
known stream sniper so trick actually
messaged Wardell to ask him if he was
duoed with him and Wardell just said nah
and obviously he was lying tck even
asked him a second time but Mell lied
once more and said he was queued up with
the omen on his team
instead wow look at that gun
actually oh
wow one bullet jet St I think he's close
Mark oh my
so so cringe I'm actually shocked at
what I'm like when missing at the moment
this is the most cringe [__] I've ever
seen
SM cring tck was pissed about the whole
situation as anyone would be but Wardell
put the blame on trick for not streaming
with any sort of delay stream with no
delay and then complain to get stream
sniped like it really shouldn't be that
hard it's actually so bad it's like not
good to stream snip but it's also like
you can do something about it now stream
sniping games has been a problem since
the early days of live streaming and I
don't expect it to go away anytime soon
there will always be shitty people out
there who would rather cheat than try to
win fairly and considering Wardell used
to be a pretty big valerant streamer
you'd think that he would understand
that nobody really wants to stream with
delay if they actually want to interact
with their Community wardell's response
was pretty shitty but I'm honestly still
shocked that he willingly queued up with
a stream sniper like what are you doing
man is he not scared that he might get
banned I guess not this same stream
sniper has been called out by other
players for the past month and even
proudly posts Clips where he's clearly
stream sniping on his Twitter and he
still hasn't been banned and after his
match against Terrick he was getting
called out even more wait this
guy this guy's watching the stream so
closely that he said Trick's messaging
you don't snitch no wo's actually for
this I'm sorry and I didn't want to
pursue it any further cuz I don't know
what's going on with wo why why is he
doing why is he doing this this is not
him like what the is he doing why is he
playing with some head like that I tuned
into wardell's stream the following day
just to see if he was talking about it
at all and here's what he said yesterday
was Shameless just don't K with that a
guy again I am the
beginning probably
shouldn't but like the smart thing is
not to do it again but it's so bad
though I shouldn't let people dictate
would I would I do or not he really
didn't seem to be taking it too
seriously but given the discussions
surrounding his actions this past week I
think it's fair to say that his
reputation has taken a pretty big hit
because of all this ordell was once at
the top of the valerant scene when TSM
was dominating the early days of the
game and now he's out here queuing with
stream snipers still don't know why he
felt the need to do it but it's weird as
hell anyways once everyone saw the whole
back and forth between trick and Wardell
valerant coach H Jen decided to weigh in
it's super cringe super super super
super super cringe of
Wardell
however I also think it's a bit
hypocritical for these players to be
complaining that the competitive
Integrity of their ranked games is being
hurt when they proceed to log on a
platinum account to Doo qu with
lwig or nade shot an ascendant or
whatever like trik it's the same thing
both things are cringe the stream
sniping super cringe guy should be
banned you also shouldn't be ruining
Platinum Games or ascendant games it's
also an unfair Advantage it's the same
thing now I'm a fan of wuhuan I think he
makes some great educational valerant
content and I get what he was trying to
say here but trik initially didn't
really see the problem his argument was
that when he cues with his lower ELO
friends he's not try Harding and
dropping 30 bombs every game he's
usually messing around and trying to let
them do the heavy lifting I'm not
justifying what I'm doing but I will I
am pointing out the fact
that in the way I'm doing it is not the
same as your typical Smurf which I agree
those guys are dog [__] and they're a
bunch of little [__] that can't play
in their own ELO so they play on their
Smurf accounts because they know that if
they play on their main they're going to
d rank cuz they're actually ass but
eventually tck came around and admitted
that maybe he shouldn't be smurfing
either I guess I am trying to take the
highway out of here [__] this guy he
really got on my nerves here cuz he's
right he's right bro I'm a Smurf too so
similar to what I said earlier about
stream sniping I don't expect smurfing
to ever really disappear it's just
something that we all have to deal with
in basically any game that has some sort
of rank system and streamers aren't the
only victim of it we can all get smurfed
on from time to time and it sucks that
being said I do think Riot could do more
to help deter players from smurfing
perhaps linking a phone number to their
account in order to play ranked would
help too that's already a requirement
for Premiere and I know some players
will still find a way around it but at
least you're adding some extra steps so
some of these players might not even
want to bother smurfing Riot did
recently make a change to ranked
matchmaking so ascendant players can
only invite players who are plat and up
to their competitive party so hopefully
this means that I won't see as many
boosted animals and Smurfs in some of my
ranked lobbies but it still doesn't help
a good chunk of the community stream
sniping and smurfing is a shitty thing
to do but I'd like to hear what you guys
think let me know down in the comments
what you think Riot could change to help
this problem I actually did a raid last
night cuz I was like every every night
before we film a donut at me I get a
sick drop I didn't get a sick drop last
night I did one raid only though to be
fair and then I went on valerin and
dranked and was really sad